hello and welcome to Big Ideas live
today at this Sky News special event we
are hoping to answer one really big
question who owns the future well
welcome and come on in because to do
that today we have invited the very best
of Business Leaders in science and
technology some of the biggest thinkers
and innovators uh we've got the UK
atomic energy Authority here and spot
the dog I've got a feeling he is going
to be taking center stage and steal a
lot of the Limelight there he is more of
a hot spot the dog later and of course
we've got our award-winning team of Sky
News journalists on hand as well well
what a week it's been for big Tech the
likes of meta and Twitter could be a big
day for Twitter today with that in mind
we're asking the question what happens
next to Big tech companies we're also
going to be talking about space space is
big business but do we really need to
keep spending sending people up into
space and spending uh for that matter
and plus we're talking about artificial
in intelligence should these huge
advances in AI be a concern or actually
should they be celebrated
we're going to be showcasing so much
great technology here today as well at
Big Ideas live all the technology that's
helping us make big leaps forward in
science in sport and in dating and we'll
be considering the question about what
the UK has to do to become a science and
technology superpower so some big
questions there and big questions of
course need big ideas and who better to
get the ball rolling than our Sky News
Science and Technology team
the scientists have done it and they've
used the virus itself to fulfill the
kind of biological Jiu Jitsu to turn the
virus on itself in the form of a vaccine
the first live Omicron variants now
they've got the sample they can grow it
up infect human cells with it in this
laboratory how long will it be until the
physical and digital collide
and the online world
tangible
as this
look no hands speak to the automotive
industry and they'll tell you that the
technology of automated driving is
effectively already here we're in a
Bitcoin boom and this is the frontier
a visible military campaign against
Islamic State was mixed with the more
covert one with cyber spies targeting
the group's ability to use phones and
other devices to communicate
these British weapons are vital for
Ukraine giving troops the ability to hit
valuable Russian targets at a distance
with precision
[Music]
and this water is rain that has fallen
on the soil come through the Rock
and as you can see it's been so dry
there really isn't much of it
delaying climate action will simply dial
up the heat
are you feeling that there's still real
Anger from developing nations that
wealthy nations are not doing enough
sure I think
understandable
feel burning cold and emitting a lot of
carbon dioxide but that is on the cusp
of changing when green steel becomes
commercially available in a few years
time it will cost more if you're any
doubt about how significant these new
images are I wish you could be in this
room already just with these first five
images we've seen things we've never
seen before this is a mock-up of
Columbus which is the European
laboratory on board the space station go
Jeff go Marco poly go Oliver you are
going for space
[Music]
just what on Earth happens next to Big
tech companies particularly companies uh
like meta and Twitter
um well hopefully Sky technology
correspondent role of manthorpe and his
guests can answer that next question uh
they're chatting amongst themselves
already so they're well prepped Roland
over to you thanks SJ
what happens next
the answer to that question has not felt
this uncertain for a long time because
it has truly been a tumultuous a frankly
at times shocking uh period in Tech over
the last few weeks it feels as if
decades have passed in mere days
and I want to start by reflecting that
and talking about that uh with the most
brilliant panel we have uh over here
Corey Dr o uh one of um the generations
great science fiction writers uh a
blogger an activist
um I'm not someone who knows his
software a long time ago he founded a
peer-to-peer networking company we also
have uh amber Gara a um serial web free
entrepreneur what does web3 mean well
we'll talk about that later
um and also exec chair at decentralize
the first uh in real life and metaverse
Music Festival
and hopefully behind us in the script
it's working in the screen we have Chris
Kelly uh and now an investor who was the
25th employee at Facebook as it was
known then where he was head of privacy
so a really fantastic panel to discuss
this question what comes next
I want to start by asking you all the
same question
in the last few weeks what has surprised
or shocked you most of all the things
that happened what has truly surprised
you Chris what about you what what was
it completely unexpected of all the
things that have happened
I I mean I think that the the radical
change inside Twitter is probably the
biggest surprise of of the of the week
um and a fact that it would go from uh
you know it's a central Town Square for
the world to you know will it work
tomorrow
um it's a pretty big
um you know set of questions and and I
you know I think it probably will
certainly work tomorrow I think it's
still going to be uh an impressive Town
Square for the world but the the massive
cutbacks and the sort of Chainsaw that
that Elon Musk has taken to the company
um it doesn't bode well for its future
what about you what's surprised or
shocked you I mean you must have been
pretty shocked when FDX for those who
don't know FTX is a cryptocurrency
Exchange
a little like a a bank this is not a
good analogy but a little like a bank
for cryptocurrencies why do
cryptocurrencies which are meant to be
totally decentralized have things like
Banks
why indeed but anyway this this entity
completely has completely imploded in
the most dramatic fashion in the last
few weeks and whereas someone who works
in this space I mean I was shocked you
must have been stunned you know what is
really really frustrating for me and
other people in this space is that what
we saw in crypto especially in
centralized decentralized Finance is
that people are making the same mistakes
that have led to the financial crisis of
2008 like the same mistake it's like you
did not learn for the mistake of your
older brothers and all and older sisters
and what we saw in FTX and in other uh
in other Landers cd5 lenders is that
there's no counterparty risk management
no risk management no internal controls
and basically if the regulation that
were created after the financial crisis
of 2008 to limit the power of the banks
the power of the hedge fund and create
more transparency in the system where
applied to this these crypto companies
we would have had maybe we would have
had the same Fiasco but it would have
been less less shocking you've been I
you know a prominent and uh you know
very strong critic of big Tech and
crypto over the years
were you were you surprised were you
were you all the same were you shocked
at what just happened so I I think that
big tax uh hype machine wants us to
think that they're Evil Geniuses they
want us to think that they've figured
out how to hack our dopamine loops and
make uh uh addictive technology but when
you look really closely at what they do
they just have monopolies right what
they've got is like a platform that they
got all your uh the people that you love
and care about and want to transact with
or go on a date with and they've locked
them into a silo and so you know what
they've done is use access to the
capital markets to build these big
impregnable silos to buy everyone who
wants to compete with them Mark
Zuckerberg gets up in the middle of the
night and sends an email to a CFO saying
young people hate Facebook they like
Instagram we have to buy Instagram
because quote it is better to buy than
to compete right this is the kind of
thing you absolutely don't want to put
in writing it's like saying let's do a
murder and premeditate it and make sure
that we premeditate it because we know
Murder is wrong right it's just not
something you want to write down but on
the recent events I feel like
the thing that surprised me was how
quickly this thing that we knew could
happen but which it seemed like the laws
of gravity had been suspended for a
decade and it seems like very quickly
people are going I don't need Twitter
and Facebook as much as I used to think
I needed them and now that the people I
love are leaving maybe I won't spend as
much time you know I know that that
Twitter uh views are up but I think
they're up in the same way that like
people crowding around a burning
building to watch it go down for those
of you who don't know Mark Zuckerberg
has invested I think it is 36 billion
dollars in his dream of a virtual
reality world the metaverse and so far
produced
I mean like not a lot so it's very
expensive bet and he's bet he's betting
the whole company on it Corey yes or no
do you believe that we will have a
metaverse I I think it's nonsense I
think it was created to distract us from
Mark Zuckerberg's inability to have a
second good idea uh and he he um and so
he's just uh trying to conjure something
into existence he's done this once
before you remember the pivot to video
where he convinced every media company
in the world to waste billions by lying
to them about how many videos people
were watching now he's doing it by lying
about the fact that we all want to be
legless low polygon cartoon characters
okay uh but it's it all amounts to the
same thing now so thank you say it
second lightning question uh Chris will
Twitter exist in a year yes or no
Twitter the the platform the service yes
but it may be a shell of its former self
okay I I agree the subscript the new
subscription model is not gonna please a
lot of people around
so so you think it will exist but people
won't be happy with it yeah it will
exist but you will have less users okay
yeah the future compost the past it's
not going away you know you can still
get a live Journal account of course
we'll still have Twitter whether or not
it matters is the important question oh
so let's get another question I think
Melanie's in the audience has got a
question
ah there you are thanks if you could
just wait for the mic to come around
there you go
thank you okay so I was wondering to
what extent do you think the spread of
fake news and increasing political
polarization has contributed to the loss
of users from platforms such as Twitter
and how can this be combat it I wanted
to ask I mean you were at Facebook very
early you were Global legal counselor I
think it was effectively the head lawyer
I mean how much of a role did did
questions of Truth and misinformation
and disinformation play in the
discussions while you were there
we we had to deal with them all the time
I mean we saw the the the initial
um aspects of misinformation campaigns
for being built around elections
um as early as 2000 and
2016 in 2008 um we we had actually
um done a number of projects to try to
increase Civic engagement on the
platform
um at that time and we certainly saw
people try to use misinformation to
manipulate elections
um early on at that phase and and fought
against it
hang on I'm sorry I've just got to pick
this up because Chris you just said that
you saw manipulation of Elections from
2006 but Mark Zuckerberg has admitted
that he didn't really take this
seriously until 2016.
I mean what happened in the interview in
10 years the scale the scale the scale
changed and uh and there were quite a
number of of folks who had I I had left
at that point um actually to you know to
to uh engage in politics on my own um
and and but we we had definitely seen um
some attempts at electoral
misinformation in the earlier races okay
thank you to my fantastic panel Chris
Kelly
[Applause]
um
and thank you all for uh for watching
and uh contributing May the argument
begin SJ over to you plenty going on
around the stages today trying to keep
my voice down because I don't want to
interrupt the experience of the two
people behind me who are here at our
tree hugger stand now this is incredible
it's entering
a tree trunk and exploring inside the
tree you can walk in and out you can
explore the world of trees and the
forest these guys have been here for at
least 15-20 minutes and there's a
massive queue to come and have a go at
this today Roland actually said this is
the best thing he has ever experienced
and that says a lot coming from our
technology correspondent
and so that is the tree hugger stand
here just one of many information
Innovation stands that we have here at
Big Ideas live plenty more panels coming
up for you as well uh in the future
stage which is just to my left
um Thomas Moore our science
correspondent is going to be talking
about the advance of technology and in
particular AI in the field of medicine
and on the main stage the festival stage
uh we'll be talking about technology in
the battlefield and how it's changing
warfare that's with our security defense
editor Deborah Haynes and special guests
welcome to this panel on cyber warfare
and how technology is changing the
battlefield and I'm joined by an expert
panel
um of of people first of all we've got
Sarah Armstrong Smith who is the chief
security advisor in Europe for Microsoft
which plays a key role in cyber security
we've also got Nigel Inkster who is an
expert a senior advisor at The
International Institute for strategic
studies looking at cyber security and
China and before that he had a long and
distinguished career at Britain's secret
intelligence service MI6 and last but
definitely not least we have Sally
Walker who spent about 25 years in
National Security ending up as director
of cyber at gchq and she led the effort
to create the national cyber force which
is a fundamental part now of UK cyber
security both offensively and
defensively we're also going to be
joined by a minister from Ukraine in a
few minutes but I thought to start off
with given that Ukraine the war in
Ukraine is so current in our minds and
cyber has played such a fundamental role
in that conflict and we we're learning
so much all the time that I'd ask the
three of you starting with Sarah just
what part has cyber played in the war in
Ukraine yeah thank you Deborah what
we're seeing now is a real example of a
hybrid War so we're used to thinking
about war as the physical kinetic war
that we get to see on the television so
we see the missiles when it's land sea
and air but the Cyber element is the
invisible element and that's kind of one
of the key areas where we talk about
hybrid War so when we have the kinetic
well we have cyber attacks exactly the
same time and this is a prime example
particularly when we talk about Ukraine
so as the tanks were rolling in on the
24th of February actually the first
strikes were the day before on the 23rd
of February Microsoft in particular
detected over 300 simultaneous cyber
attacks and this was really trying to
knock out as much as Ukraine's critical
infrastructure as quickly as possible so
Nigel what's your thoughts about the war
in Ukraine and how cyber is playing a
part in it well I you know I think you
know I would say yes everything that you
know Sarah's just said I agree with but
I think the lesson I'm taking from this
is that ultimately cyber plays an
ancillary role a very important role and
in sometimes a vital role but it's
probably utility its utility is probably
um in the kind of Gray Zone area that
precedes actual armed conflict and as
Sarah said in the information Warfare
domain
targeting populations around the world
and uh
um trying to persuade them of the
validity of Russia's message and while
that may not be working terribly well in
our part of the world in what they call
the global South it is actually working
rather effectively
we're going to be speaking now to George
dabinski if technology
survives uh there he is thank you ever
so much he is Ukraine's Deputy digital
transformation minister right on the
physical front line and absolutely the
virtual front line Minister thank you
ever so much for joining us here at Big
Ideas live can you just give us a sense
from your perspective of how cyber is
playing a role in this war in your
country how fundamental a role is that
good afternoon girl thank you for having
me and you know I heard just a very wise
comments from my colleagues and I share
them and in general but I would say I
would Advocate a few things exactly
cyber became one of the dimensions of
this hybrid Warfare together with
information Warfare so kinetic cyber
information constructs this war and I
would say that we have ongoing the first
online War because of everyone is able
to follow the words of the social media
platform and the more broader context I
would say that it's not only cyber but I
would say that we are talking about some
digital uh digital security and digital
resonance because of as my colleagues
mentioned uh
uh we have cyber attacks very critical
component we experience more than 1
370 cyber attacks and you know cyber
incidents it's more than 65 000. Sally
what do you what do you make of what the
minister just said there about how cyber
is uh you know this you have to defend
against it but of course he's clearly
saying you also have to be offensive and
I know you don't like those terms but so
can you just explain to us yeah you know
what your thoughts are and also more
broadly how you would describe the Cyber
threat
so I think The Minister's comments just
reinforced the backdrop to this
conversation which is our society is
digitally dependent uh in everything
that we do from the classroom to the
boardroom to the front line
and every
um decision that we make is derived from
information
whether that information is trusted or
not is critical to whether we're
competent and that's whether we're
competent as a whole society
so in the context of cyber warfare yes
cyber is technology and yes cyber is I.T
but I think it would be deeply dangerous
for the debate to stop there because
cyber is completely a human challenge
um a deeply human challenge
and therefore we need to be thinking
about how we build National competence
National resilience and making sure that
that competences across the whole of our
society Nigel can you just give your
thoughts uh we're talking about cyber
technology more broadly and the future
how is Warfare in the future going to
look
well you know we're back to close a bit
you know the difference between the the
the nature and the character of warfare
you know as close of it said you know
the nature of warfare is unchanging but
the character of warfare changes
continuously the other thing to say is
you know remind ourselves as Warfare is
a complex adaptive process and victory
normally goes to the side that proves
most adaptive so making uh predictions I
think is very difficult but there are
certain things I think we can safely
assume one as I just said I think at the
end of the day you know cyber
um attacks I mean I don't like the term
cyber warfare I'm not sure what it means
nor does anybody else
um you know is is probably going to be
Preparatory and ancillary to the main
event which is still going to be a clash
of arms the other thing to think about
is the whole challenge of autonomous
systems and the United Nations has got
very exercised about this and is looking
at the whole question of Killer Robots
well I think we're a long way from that
you know no serious military thinker or
Commander that I know about wants you
know to find himself in a situation
where artificial intelligence systems or
machines are dictating the battle
rhythms and if we look at what's
happened in Ukraine the role of the
human being I think is still fundamental
Ukrainian forces have defeated a much
larger and on the face of it better
prepared Force Through you know the
skill of individual commanders you know
non-commissioned officers on the ground
and I don't think we're ever going to be
able to eliminate that from a central
role in Conflict well um Richie sunac
our new prime minister is actually just
visiting Ukraine at the moment for the
first time he's been meeting with the
president and he's been saying about how
the UK is going to be providing more
weapons to help the ukrainians like what
is the biggest assistance that the UK
can give Ukraine to help deal with these
threats in the Cyber domain actually
Sally if I go to you first
brain power so this is a human endeavor
this is about the skills that we need
and it's about different thinking
and if you bring together brilliant
people who understand
telecommunications networks devices
Logistics supplies
weapons programs you can then work with
those individuals to make their systems
more safe because if you're an engineer
building something you don't tend to
think I wonder how this can be broken
but that's what our adversaries are
doing to us well it's time now to hear
from someone helping to make those
decisions about freedom of expression
and designing or deciding what content
is appropriate with that I'm going to
hand over to our technology
correspondent Ray lamantho thanks SJ I'm
so delighted to be here with Dex Hunter
Turek of the Facebook uh meta I should
say uh oversight board
um one of the most interesting and
unique experiments in one of the most
important areas the moderation of what
we can and can't put online Dex welcome
good to be here let's just start by
helping me understand the principles
underlying the oversight board the way
we've looked at it is uh to make
decisions about content for a global set
of platforms Facebook and Instagram have
billions of users around three billion
we need to have members on an
independent body who represent the huge
diversity of that user base many
different backgrounds many different
communities who can help solve some of
those really complex challenges that
users are facing every single day on
those platforms so the the question or
the topic of oversight boards and
content moderation boards has really
come up recently because Elon Musk said
that he'd like one for Twitter
who worked for Elon Musk
um what advice would you have for him on
this topic well look I think um the
first thing I would say when looking at
Twitter and how to moderate content
there is you have to start with the
principle of Do no harm and I mean that
in the sense that medical professionals
look at Patients when you make decisions
here uh you know four platforms like
Twitter which are part of the critical
infrastructure of free expression around
the world for you know many millions of
people including activists people who
are you know struggling for Better Lives
for democracy in societies facing
Conflict for decisions you make in
California can be immensely
consequential and so actually making a
very rapid you know knee-jerk decisions
about the direction of content about
content policy that's probably not the
right way to go from the oversight board
perspective what we have you know
repeatedly you know encouraged better to
do with how they moderate content is to
be transparent about how they make
decisions
um really to show how they've come to a
decision so that it builds trust with
users
um trust in social media companies and
in business I think has taken an
absolute rollicking over recent years
and certainly I think it will not be
helpful for restoring trust if you have
uh Elon making decisions where people
wonder is this being driven mainly
because of elon's personal preferences I
do think as well if you're building a
Content Council it has to genuinely
operate independently from the company
it cannot be something that just
reflects elon's personal preferences
yeah because as you
um refer to the key decision when meta
set up or Facebook as it was then set up
the oversight board was that Mark
Zuckerberg essentially stepped back and
said you take over this he didn't
actually step back all the way but he
did step back a little bit I mean you
know Elon Musk right does he have the
self-discipline uh the self-control
I I mean just does he have the character
to take a decision like that yeah I mean
um Elon is somebody who famously
describes himself not as a micromanager
but as a nano manager uh he's somebody
who uh often likes to be very involved
in things that are quite intricate and
you think other CEOs might not be uh
that invested in in that element
um you know certainly um I think that
sounds like a no uh I I think based on
the last couple of weeks I think it's a
couple of weeks though it seems longer
um he is unlikely uh to be uh very
detached from these decisions we'll have
to see how it unfolds I mean I
understand that he's probably minded to
bring in another CEO to run Twitter so
he can go back to focusing on other
parts of his business
um interests and that would probably be
the right way to go I think Twitter
needs a lot of attention and if elon's
going to be providing that I wonder
who's going to be running the shop at
Tesla and SpaceX and just to say is that
essentially is that if the overlord of
the company is involved in a project
like the oversight board it can't work
can it
yeah I mean uh the oversight board
operates completely independently from
the political the commercial the public
relations interests of uh meta uh we you
know frankly don't care what Mark
Zuckerberg thinks about the decisions we
make
um we are there to advocate for users to
ensure that users are being treated
fairly um Elon does not need to be
involved he should not be involved in
making those incredibly consequential
decisions well our next panel now is all
about artificial intelligence and the
question can AI replace your brain
hosting this panel our data and
forensics correspondent Tom jeshire
thank you very much Sarah Jane
um yeah we're going to be talking about
machines that think we're going to be
looking at questions that have baffled
philosophers for thousands of years
nature of Consciousness and we're going
to solve that in about 45 minutes flat I
reckon so I've got an expert panel to
help me do that
um annel Seth who is the professor of
cognitive and computational Neuroscience
and the author of being you a new
science of communication uh Dr Catherine
Breslin a machine learning scientist and
founder of Kingfisher Labs Consulting
previously worked at Cambridge
University Toshiba research and on a
little thing called Amazon Alexa which
you might have heard of and finally Dr
Chris Bishop laboratory director at
Microsoft research Cambridge which I've
been a couple of times this is Treasure
Trove of very Advanced research and also
a member of the UK AI Council so I think
we're in very safe hands here thank you
all for joining us here artificial
intelligence it's strange because it's a
term that's been around a long time but
it also seems to refer something that
hasn't quite arrived yet but it's all
around us we're using it the whole time
I wonder Catherine if you could start us
with that what does AI look like in the
world right now so I think it's a very
good point that AI is a really
ill-defined term and I don't think it
has you know a real concrete definition
of what it is and so the best I can come
up with is computers trying to sort of
emulate some sort of human intelligence
and obviously we're a very long way from
and hopefully we'll get to that question
of how closer are we to human
intelligence but we're on the path to
computers that are becoming more and
more intelligent and I think if we look
at some of the ways that technology is
used right now in the world we can see
some real good examples of artificial
intelligence and how it's used you
mentioned Alexa obviously that is a I
think I think a very nice example of how
AI is working at the moment and if you
have Alexa or you've talked to Siri or
any of these other virtual assistants
you might have a sense of how good the
technology is you know it can listen to
you it can understand certain things it
does a lot of smart stuff behind the
scenes but also it has some limitations
I'm not going to say that it's solved um
conversation and so you get a sense of
these sort of limitations and potential
if you look at things that are out there
in the real world what are you most
excited by in terms of the applications
of AI well I think we've seen huge
advances even just in the last couple of
years or so and it's sort of become
ubiquitous so there are many many places
that AI shows up in our daily lives that
we don't know about I mean I think one
you know Arthur Clark the science
fiction writer once said you know the
the best Technologies ones that
disappear into the into the background
they help you in your daily lives you're
not aware of it so it's just all sorts
of things like you know opening your
phone with your face or
um translating from one language to
another on a website or just many many
many examples of this
um but I do have a real sense that the
and I've been in the field for about 35
years I mean the field has been called
machine learning that I've been in and
rather than artificial intelligence but
it's really a machine learning has
really become the dominant approach to
artificial intelligence and really just
in the last year or two we've seen just
extraordinary advances to the point
where
um I think the next few years in
particular will see some very rapid
changes
Consciousness is not the same thing as
intelligence and I think this is a
crucial distinction to make because it
so often said like
not by anyone here of course but in the
wider public that that Consciousness is
some function of intelligence that once
AI crosses some threshold then the
lights come on and it's not only going
to be smart it's going to be sentient
but I think this is
comes from a place of human
exceptionalism we think we're really
special as humans we think we're
intelligent and we know we're conscious
so we think the things go together but
Consciousness we should Define it
actually I mean Consciousness is really
any kind of experience whatsoever it
feels like something to be a conscious
system
uh you can an experience of pain or of
seeing color
is is enough you know you don't have to
have complex cognition going on uh in
order to be be conscious so there's no
real good reason to expect that simply
ratcheting up intelligence is going to
make uh an AI system conscious
and just by observing apparently
intelligent Behavior I don't think it's
a reliable signature of whether the
thing is conscious and I think we can be
misled here systems can give us a strong
intuition that there's a conscious mind
there when there's just the whirring of
algorithms why do you think we have this
obsession with wanting to have conscious
machines as Sarah James is saying it's
such a Trope of Science Fiction you know
some brilliant films about it some bad
films about it as well it's something we
clearly feel the need to see in the
world why is that Catherine I think
you're right it is a Trope of Science
Fiction and we we want to emulate
ourselves somehow in what we do and so
people are driven to build replicas of
people build technology which just like
us but if you look back over time you
see that it's been a constant threat
through the history of technology that
people have wanted to assign human
agency to technology even to other
inanimate objects you'll hear people
talking about how their you know their
TV is annoyed with them or something
like that we assign human human
properties to technology into other
things there's a famous example of a
chatbot which was built back in the 60s
called Eliza which was very simple chat
but it was a therapist it had some
canned answers so you you tell it your
problem and it might say can you tell me
more about that or sometimes it would
flip your your question back on you so
you might say I'm feeling unhappy and it
will say can you tell me why you're
feeling unhappy very simple responses
and the the creator of this program
wanted to show how stupid computers were
but but people did believe that Eliza
had human like intelligence and and the
Creator was very surprised by this that
he could I had the opposite effect
and and I think that this trend has sort
of carried on through people are really
Keen to assign human properties to
computers especially when they're using
language and other human-like animations
and and that sort of thing this question
of why do we feel like this is something
we need in our world in our lives I
think really does need to be
interrogated because just as much as we
don't know what it would take to build a
machine that has experience we also
don't know what it wouldn't take and we
might do it by accident we might not
know if we've done it and if if this
happens it would be an ethical
catastrophe because soon as something
can have experience
we have an ethical obligation to it to
minimize its potential suffering
and if we don't even know the criteria
by which to establish whether that's
even a possibility we're in really
really deep Waters so just building
something because it sounds cool and
you've seen it in science fiction and
you want to be at The Cutting Edge of
this pivotal moment in in human history
is a really really terrible idea so I I
think that these
goals of building actually conscious AI
are are just wrong we should not be
trying to do that thank you so much all
the panelists I think we solved
everything we got there in 45 minutes
thank you very much for being here and
for watching along at home and sending
in all those questions and there's
plenty more to come here Big Ideas live
take a look at this the UK atomic energy
Authority are here with us and this
is their four-legged friend it's spot
the dog
I thought that's what the dog we're used
to but this is the future at the UK's
atomic energy Authority
says that this four-legged robot can go
where humans cannot and we're going to
take spot for a little walk
um it's created a lot of interest with
our audience here in the room and we're
going to bring spots to you at home
joining me sunshi Chen from the UK aea
and senshi talk to me about spot I mean
he's drawn a lot of attention he can
walk up the stairs and talk to me about
the technology behind him
so we actually use spot for inspection
purposes like you said we use spot to go
places where people can't so places that
are potentially hazardous for humans
they might have high radiation they
might have latent heat and spot has
cameras on the front infrared cameras
just normal visual cameras to give us uh
you know an overview of these of of
these environments so that we know
what's going on and it's technology like
this that we can apply to Fusion Energy
yes so talk to me about Fusion Energy
because this is the the friendly face
this is the cute fun bit that draws
people in but the energy that goes into
this technology is the serious business
exactly so in a in a sentence it's a sun
in a bottle what we're trying to do is
recreate the process that the sun uses
Fusion to create energy here on Earth
um we call these things you know Fusion
machines
um and we want to we want to make them
to basically create you know sustainable
low carbon and secure energy these
things this type of energy technology is
a very efficient very efficient
technology very secure technology and
very safe and it's you know going to be
part of the energy mix in the latter
half of the century to provide energy
security for everybody Yeah you
mentioned all the white right words
they're clean renewable and secures the
energy we've been talking about so much
about that so far this year just a final
question from Youth and chief I can't a
personal one I mean obviously how did
how did you get into Tech and science
because you know we've got younger
members of the audience here today and
are watching on at home or on the Move
wherever they are today and this could
be the hook that gets them into Science
and Tech what was your journey into this
field so I always liked science even as
a small kid and then I went into
University and I did do a nuclear
specific degree but that's not necessary
to get into this kind of technology or
into science at all if you have an
interest in science that's enough and
then I joined on to The Graduate scheme
here at the UK aea which is brilliant
you know we really value trying to bring
up our younger Engineers which is vital
to a rapidly growing and a rapidly
changing industry that is Fusion one of
the really big challenges for the future
is climate change of course and how we
can get people to eat less meat now the
government's climate advisors say we
need to reduce meat consumption by
around the third and that's a lot one of
the companies here is called read High
meat this is a plant-based product and
as you can see it looks pretty
convincingly uh like meat and but what's
quite unique about this is that it's 3D
printed and we're joined by Edwin who's
the senior vice president of the company
how do you make 3D printed meat yeah so
actually what you're seeing here is the
fruit of four years of hard work a
collaboration with chefs with Futures
meat experts and foods high invests and
we use 3D printing technology because it
has a several benefits one of them is
that you can basically produce layer by
layer voxel by Vauxhall fat blood and
muscle to replicate a very complex
structure of meat one kilogram of meat
costs 25 kilograms of soy so it's an
extremely inefficient way to convert the
same ingredients that we use in our
products namely soy and and pea and
chickpea and wheat into meat basically
what we can do is produce one cow a day
whereas normally a cow would have to
leave for two three four years let's
give it a go Jenny you've got something
there for me to try just before we have
to move on watch this one this is the
flank steak this is the blank steak
let's just try with my fingers it's a
bit Mucky but just for the space of time
it does taste like meat
quite have the same fibrous texture
but it's pretty close
well you should actually then try also
the tenderloin it's very very quick
which is a very different texture too
not really the time of day to do this
but
now lots of companies are trying to
reproduce this mouth feel of me very
difficult to do
but by using uh technology this company
for one believes that they can do it
thanks all of you for joining us here
and those of us who are joining us for
remotely
um I hope it's going to be interesting
we have got a stellar panel here to
explore the question of can the UK
become a science superpower
um on my immediate right my left your
right uh Daniel corski CEO of public uh
former special advisor David Cameron I
understand in on these sorts of issues
and um public is a venture capital firm
uh focused on helping technology
startups transform Public Services
next we have Smart Walpole former Chief
government science advisor uh so he
knows a fair amount about how
politicians think about science and I'm
hoping he will share some of those
secrets with us but before that he was
head of the ukri which is the body that
decides how to distribute our r d budget
to the right kind of scientists in the
right way and last but not least at all
Zoe McDougall from Oxford nanopore now
if you haven't heard of their nanopore
makes scalable DNA and RNA sequencing
devices for research biodefense water
testing agriculture all sorts of bits
and you name it pretty much before we
delve into this question though I
thought we'd just take a quick listen to
our new Chancellor Jeremy Hunt what he
had to say in his budget speech on
Thursday about the UK's it's Science and
Technology position
I want to combine our technology and
science Brilliance with our formidable
Financial Services to turn Britain into
the world's next Silicon Valley I want
to go further so today I protect our
entire research budgets and confirm that
we'll increase Public Funding for r e to
20 billion by 24.25 as part of our
mission to make the United Kingdom a
science superpower
we'll get into the wording of that
statement in a second because it's it's
slightly misleading in my opinion but
we'll discuss that further but I thought
I'd just start by asking all of you guys
starting with you Dad
can the UK become a science superpower
or is it already
I think it's fair to say if we've got to
stick to the language of international
politics that we may not be a superpower
but we're sort of a rising power you
know we've got a lot of the basics right
we've got lots of great companies
nanoplowers of course one fantastic
example we've got a big uh investment
sector that's willing to pour money into
it but the truth is also we haven't
quite done all the things that we need
to do in order to build up our arsenal
we haven't been spending enough on R D
we don't have enough people studying
various stem subjects and frankly
funding isn't really what it is in the
US if you had to compare ourselves so we
can get there but there's still work to
be done and the budget we've seen has
taken some steps forward and a few steps
backwards so we'll see over the next
coming period come on superpower well I
mean the first thing is it's good news
that that is a government aim it's
really important and it really matters
for the future of the country because
we're going through an industrial
revolution amazing new technologies
amazing new businesses and we've got all
the challenges of climate demographic
change so we need to be
um we're extraordinarily good at
research there's no question about that
do we exploit it most effectively
probably not yet and the money is really
important but also the environment in
which researchers and innovators work
that's really important you know can we
continue to bring the best people from
overseas that's a really important test
so I think you know it's it's all good
news but there is a huge amount to do
yeah I want to get into the money and
those other issues in just a second Zoe
superpower or not uh we are the center
of southernmost extraordinary science
and Innovation and I think we can talk
about Academia but we can also talk
about industrial r d which is a huge
focus in this country and we are amazing
at spin outs and you've obviously funded
many of them but we're not so good at
scale up and the life sciences
industrial strategy that was published
about three years ago said we the UK
should have in the next few years at
least four con four companies worth 20
billion pounds we're not quite there yet
our scale up our Ambitions really have
to be bigger as a country the government
has protected the r d budget Jeremy Hunt
there in the comments saying he'd raised
it by 20 billion 20 billion pounds sorry
in fact that was the pre-existing
commitment they maintained science
funding but this is in effect a doubling
of where we were before so are we
spending off I thought I'd start with
Gmail
um
well I mean you know what's the right
amount to spend on research and
development we are if you look at it as
a percentage of uh GDP we're still not
in the Forefront so we are perhaps about
2.4 at the moment if you take into
account the recent ons calculations
U.S Germany Korea we're at three percent
in 2020. so it's good it's heading in
the right direction but it doesn't put
us by any means amongst the world
leaders the name of this whole uh event
is who owns the future and I thought I'd
put that to it it just a quick thought
if you could certainly perhaps starting
with you we've got such a firm opinion
on this so you have challenges across
the world that genomics can answer it's
health challenges it's environmental
challenges food security challenges 30
of the food that is produced goes to
waste because of pathogens and pests in
the world extraordinary and those
problems are experienced by the people
who are not where the Innovation is
happening so we want to make our
technology we want to tear down those
barriers so the people who have the
challenges are the people who are
creating the solutions for those
problems so I guess our answer to that
was we think the future belongs to the
people with the problems to solve so
that they can drive the solving of those
problems I mean you own the future in
the sense that it has never been easier
than today to define a problem and build
Solutions attract people to help you
money to support you and and access the
architecture you need to build something
whether that's a software architecture
or or more physical architecture and
then access markets immediately Beyond
you or further field it has never have
been easier never been easier so the
future belongs to you but the great news
is that you have the the levers at your
disposal to do something about it in a
way no previous generation had as easily
hello welcome back to Big Ideas live and
we're here in our Innovation section
you're looking at the future of Fitness
not me not my reflection but that lady
there this is echelon Fitness they've
been displaying their Fitness mirror
um it really is incredible what's been
going on here we've got 3D printers over
there to my left sorry people are
filming these this is how technological
it is you're feeding me they're filming
me there's lots of machines around them
3D printer there that um scientists are
using uh to print organs that actually
help uh sign and help neurosurgeons and
other surgeons uh practice on organs
we've got dating VR here we've got two
people having a go I'm not sure if
they're dating each other
uh I'm not sure maybe we can find out
afterwards this is very much a
futuristic blind date but that's the
future of dating and we've got so much
going on here but now it is time to talk
about the global Space Race yes space is
back it's back in the news there is so
much happening NASA is hoping to spend
uh send astronauts back to the Moon by
2026.
um here in Britain the first Spaceport
in Cornwall that received the green
light and we could see Rockets launch
from there possibly by the end of this
month
and of course there are all the
billionaires in the business world of
space making money out space space
tourism the likes of Elon Musk we've
heard a little bit about him today uh
Jeff Bezos as well and Sir Richard
Branson all planning on sending tourists
into orbit on a regular basis in the
very near future so as I said space is
back
staff United launch Alliance Atlas V
rocket
[Music]
three two
[Music]
six Decades of the Space Race have left
more than nine thousand tons of debris
in orbit go Jeff go Marco poly go Oliver
you are going to space Virgin Galactic
and SpaceX release huge amounts of
carbon dioxide to all to give the
privileged few a taste of weightlessness
and a spectacular view of the planet if
we can do this
just imagine what you can do hey
[Music]
enough of Artemis one we rise together
back to the moon and Beyond
let's talk all things space leading this
panel for us our science correspondent
Thomas Moore Sarah Jane thank you so
much oh my word looking those images
don't you just want to go to space wow I
would love to do it
um look I mean the space race is so
different now it used to be a two-horse
race between the United States and the
Soviet Union now there's a long list of
space-faring Nations and companies uh
it's not just about the flag planting
anymore it's about the science there's
money to be made and our everyday lives
are being affected by what's going on in
space Our Lives depend on it so to
discuss the how and the why I'm joined
by an expert panel we've got Melissa
Thorpe uh the boss of Spaceport Cornwall
now just days away from launching a
rocket from the runway of Nuki airport
we've got Lord Reese Martin Reeser a
world-renowned cosmologist and the
astronomer Royal a post I read created
by Charles II no less to map the night
sky and is it true you get a hundred
pounds a year still does it get that you
don't even get that or bad luck I think
you can demand it and also from New
Mexico we're joined by Mike Moses there
we are Mike uh with with the unity in in
the background there your your
Mothership uh he is president of Virgin
Galactic who's on a countdown uh to the
company's first commercial flights for
space tourists early next year fingers
crossed Mike and we'll also be going
live shortly uh to a NASA astronaut and
that's going to be really exciting
Melissa let's start with you
I mean goodness me it's exciting to a
thinker a rocket launch from the UK
yeah I mean it is still a bit surreal
eight years ago we used to get laughed
at but who's laughing now um we're very
close to launching for the first time
ever from UK soil
um from Cornwall and it's just been such
a roller coaster ride
um but it's all coming to fruition now
down in Cornwall and and we're really
just proud of what this is about to do
for the UK but let's be clear this isn't
a NASA style vertical launch to space
you've got some other idea tell us about
what you're going to be doing down in
Newquay yeah absolutely so we're working
with Virgin orbits so Mike's without
Virgin Galactic we're with Virgin orbit
we're not being sponsored by the
complete coincidence I I don't represent
them but um our Spaceport is launching
our first launch with them and that
basically uses a Boeing 747 that's been
modified to carry a giant 70-foot
two-stage rocket under one of its wings
basically what it will do is go up part
way to space where it deploys that
rocket mid-air and that rocket goes into
space let me just challenge you on on
the value of sending human scientists to
Mars the robots the rovers are fantastic
but it does need some human operator
back here to help decide which rocks to
head for and they're doing that on the
basis of a two-dimensional screen isn't
it not better to send a human who can
walk the dust tap the Rocks decide where
to drill
well that's certainly true today
um the um perseverance uh uh vehicle on
Mars has enough AI to be able to work
his way around obstacles and all that
but you can't do the geology but I would
argue that long before we think of
sending people to Mars which would be 20
years from now
um the AI will be able to do the geology
too just as well as a human and of
course at vastly less cost Mike in in
New Mexico and his space tourists for
now in near Earth orbit do you have
Ambitions to uh not yet in New in in
orbit do you have Ambitions to go into
to orbit and perhaps even Beyond
yeah sure I think uh you know uh uh with
with due respect to the astronomer Royal
the the the exploration by robots is is
definitely uh a less risky thing but I
think he really diminished The
Experience feedback the question I
always got when I was at Nasa and here
at Virgin Galactic you know why do we
send people to space and and I think at
the heart of it there's a fundamental uh
human nature and while it is risky and
expensive uh it is very Noble and it
gives inspiration uh and a real purpose
and so you know here at Virgin Galactic
we're going to try to let a lot of folks
go to to uh sub orbit and be able to see
the Earth uh and experience space travel
and just a small slice let's bring in
the professional this is Nicole stock
former NASA astronaut uh two space
flights 104 days in space one spacewalk
and a spectacular spacesuit there in the
background and Nicole uh what's going on
uh well I you know nice to be here and I
appreciate hearing all the comments from
everyone
um and the spacesuit behind me is part
of its name is exploration it's part of
a program we do at the space for Art
Foundation working with kids all over
the world uniting a planetary community
of children through the awe and wonder
of space exploration and the healing
power of the Articles and I was thinking
about this this week now that uh Artemis
program is underway but going back to
the Moon which is really exciting but
those images taken by Orion looking back
at our tiny fragile Blue Marble against
that black curtain of space I mean those
kinds of images taken by the Apollo
Astronauts really helped to give birth
to the environmental movement back in
the the 60s and then 70s it is a thing
isn't it
yeah I absolutely believe it I mean like
Martin said too I
um I had I had these Vivid memories of
watching you know Neil and Buzz walking
on the moon knowing that Mike Collins
was orbiting it and you know going
outside and and looking at the moon and
being even at you know seven years old
understanding that that was a really
extraordinary thing what would you give
to be on on the rocket to to the moon
and walk there one day as let's face it
no oh my God no no woman has walked on
the moon yet I would absolutely love to
walk on the moon I love I look forward
at least to living vicariously through
my friends and others that will and
um and knowing that by establishing our
presence there you know in a more
permanent sense settling there in a
permanent way will allow us to take
advantage and and I say that in a
positive way of the resources available
on the moon for us to lift some of the
industry that we have on Earth off the
planet and into space all all for the
benefit of life on Earth thank you very
much indeed everybody for joining us a
panel here experts giving us some sense
of excitement about the future of space
Thomas thank you and to our panel I
really mean it when that was out of this
world thank you everybody thoroughly
enjoyed that that was our final session
of Big Ideas live I'm going to invite
spot back onto the stage an encore for
sport because I didn't ask the key
question in our interview earlier spot
which is whether you can dance
apparently he can for those of you who
are staying with us there's our meet the
correspondence session uh in the
Innovation area at the back but for Big
Ideas live that's it for now uh we'll
see you next time take it away spot
foreign
[Music]
[Music]